[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
the widely hated Peter Pettigrew he's
really up there with the most hated
characters of the series comparable even
to dare I say it
Umbridge Peter Pettigrew also known as
Wormtail was a British pureblood wizard
born in 1959 he had pale skin unhealthy
hair that was constantly falling out and
blue eyes he was a sniveling excuse for
a man whose loyalties only lay where
there was power and he did not value
friendship or love in the way that most
do Pettigrew started at Hogwarts in the
year 1971 the same year that Sirius
Black Remus Lupin and James Potter began
attending the school the quartet of boys
would eventually form a group called the
Marauders one thing that they all had in
common was that they were all
Gryffindor's the Marauders were
hell-bent on breaking the rules at the
school and were notorious for their rule
breaking and mischief making the group
existed for seven years from 1971 to
1978 and all members were active
participants in the first Wizarding war
all four boys would also go on to join
the order of the Phoenix which was a
secret society founded by Dumbledore
that opposed Lord Voldemort though the
boys were silly during their time at
school they did seem to mature quite a
bit after they left the school well at
least some of them did Pettigrew never
quite grew up and never really became
his own person his personality seemed to
just directly mirror those that
surrounded him and he had the least
character of the four boys he didn't
have his own identity though he joined
the order of the Phoenix along with the
other Marauders Peter ended up having a
bit of an ulterior motive
during the first Wizarding war Pettigrew
ended up being convinced to join Lord
Voldemort he wasn't confident that the
good guys would prevail and blindly
followed Voldemort in pursuit of power
sometime in the year 1979 the year
before Harry Potter was born Sybill
Trelawney gave her first prophecy
this prophecy was told in the presence
of Dumbledore during her application to
become divination professor at Hogwarts
the prophecy was as follows
the one with the power to vanquish the
Dark Lord approaches born to those who
have thrice defied him born as the
seventh month dies and the Dark Lord
will mark him as his equal but he will
have power the Dark Lord knows not and
either must die at the hand of the other
for neither can live while the other
survives the one with the power to
vanquish the Dark Lord will be born as
the seventh month dies when Sibyl told
Dumbledore the prophecy Snape then death
eater was eavesdropping at the door
Snape in a snivelling manner went
straight to Voldemort and told him of
the prophecy the boy in question could
have been one of two boys Harry Potter
or Neville Longbottom
Voldemort deduced that the boy mentioned
in the prophecy was Harry and so he
began plotting to kill the boy Snape now
concerned for larly safety mentioned to
Dumbledore that Voldemort was planning
to kill the Potters this led to the
Potters going into hiding because of his
history with James Potter and the
Marauders Pettigrew was made secret
keeper for the Potters a secret keeper
is a witch or wizard designated to hide
a secret the secret is secured by the
fidelia's charm which conceals the
secret inside of the secret keepers soul
Sirius Black was the initial choice for
secret keeper but serious thinking that
Voldemort might target him suggested
they choose Pettigrew instead the
following excerpt from Sirius dresses
this Lily and James only made you secret
keeper because I suggested it I thought
it was the perfect plan
Voldemort would be sure to come after me
would never dream they'd use a week
talentless thing like you it must have
been the finest moment of your miserable
life telling Voldemort that you could
hand him the Potters by this point
Pettigrew was already completely turned
to Voldemort side and subsequently
revealed the location of the Potters
cottage to Voldemort betraying all of
his closest friends in one massive act
of cowardice
this was the perfect example of the type
of behavior that one could expect from
the man that Pettigrew became a
sniveling disloyal man who was willing
to betray his loved ones for just some
semblance of power so if Peter was this
kind of person then how did he end up in
Gryffindor how did he end up in the
house that represents bravery and
courageousness when all that he
seemingly represents his cowardice and
disloyalty why would the sorting hat
which claims to have never made a
mistake place him there in the sorting
hat own words these are the defining
characteristics of the houses by
Gryffindor the bravest were priced far
beyond the rest for ravenclaw of the
cleverest would always be the best for
Hufflepuff hard workers were most worthy
of admission and power-hungry Slytherin
loved those of great ambition based on
the above it's hard to see how Pettigrew
fits in anywhere sure so their own
attracts those who are power-hungry and
ambitious but I'm not sure that
Pettigrew was particularly ambitious he
just wanted a shred of Voldemort's power
and was willing to become completely
subservient in order to obtain that I
don't think that he ever had any sort of
plan to usurp Voldemort not that he
really could have even if he wanted to
he wasn't even that power-hungry
he was just weak lacked willpower and
was easily swayed with very little
incentive so again why was Pettigrew
sorted into Gryffindor in the first
place when the Hat is placed on a
student's head it uses the legitimacy to
analyze their mind it then places them
in a house based on how closely they
resemble one of the four founders if the
Hat senses great bravery
Gryffindor's the likely choice if the
Hat senses great intelligence
ravenclaw is a likely choice if the Hat
senses that someone is a hard worker
hufflepuff is a likely choice and
finally if the Hat senses that someone
is hungry for power then Slytherin as a
likely choice very rarely every 50 years
or so a hat stall will occur during the
sorting hat ceremony
this is when the sorting hat needs
additional time to come up with the
decision usually it is considered a hat
stall when the decision takes five
minutes or longer this usually occurs
when a student has a personality that
could be considered equally suitable for
multiple Hogwarts houses in Pettigrew's
case the very rare hats doll actually
occurred and the Hat deliberated for
five and a half minutes on whether
Pettigrew should be placed in Slytherin
or Gryffindor after being placed into
Gryffindor Pettigrew was extremely happy
with the decision that had been made and
immediately began making friends with
Sirius James and Remus Pettigrew being a
hat stool indicates that he possessed
equal traits from Gryffindor and
Slytherin and by placing Pettigrew in
Gryffindor the sorting hat must have
recognized potential in petty group that
he perhaps never reached what this means
is that the Hat recognized something
deep down inside of Pettigrew that we
never ended up witnessing as we know the
Hat can detect nascent qualities in the
student and generally places them in the
house that will challenge on the most
putting their character to the test the
Hat may have detected that Pettigrew was
that bit of a sniveling and disloyal man
but also saw potential in him to be
great
and by placing him in Gryffindor he was
challenged to be a better person the
person that deep deep down he had the
capability of being Slytherin may have
been too easy for Pettigrew to embrace
his slimy slithery side and the sorting
hat may have known that they would
immediately be a bad influence on him
and so the Hat placed him in Gryffindor
to truly put his character to the test
one thing that I want to address is why
are we so certain the Pettigrew never
displayed any kind of bravery as we know
one of the defining characteristics of
Gryffindor is bravery but just because
you're a bad guy it doesn't necessarily
mean that you can't be brave bravery
isn't necessarily measured by your moral
compass and actually can be one of your
defining characteristics regardless of
where you fall in the good and evil
spectrum many people in the Wizarding
community entirely disassociate
themselves with werewolves but when the
Marauders found out the Remus was a
werewolf James Sirius and Pettigrew all
done how to
and Omega this can be an extremely
dangerous process and Pettigrew was
never a particularly versed wizard this
made the process extra dangerous for him
but in order to support his friend he
tried anyway and he was ultimately
successful for the most part Pettigrew
was still brave and determined just in
mostly negative ways
one other thing worth mentioning is that
the sorting hat will in some cases
consider the choice of the student the
sorting hat will analyze how you value
or admire the qualities of a particular
house good examples of this are Crabbe
and Goyle who were never ambitious or
cunning but made it into Slytherin
because they placed slytherins values in
a high regard it turns out that it is
actually possible to influence the
sorting hat with your own wishes and
desires I think that this is the key
reason that Peter Pettigrew became a
Gryffindor at the time of sorting it was
Pettigrew desire to be in Gryffindor
house he knew that the house was
regarded in a positive light and was
synonymous with bravery and power in a
lot of ways perhaps power was what
Pettigrew ultimately sought but he just
became misguided later in life on how he
would actually achieve that power his
character was weak which was his
ultimate downfall and in a weird way
Pettigrew was sort of brave because he
was willing to do dangerous things for
whoever he followed whether it was the
good guys or the bad guys Pettigrew was
a spy for Voldemort for over a year
before his true colors were revealed and
as much as I don't like to admit it this
would require some level of bravery
after all what if the Order found out in
his schoolboy days the Marauders were
popular and held power at school so he
followed their calls even if it meant
breaking some rules and in the same
fashion
when Pettigrew observed that Voldemort
held power he followed him going as far
as to cut off his own hand to provide
Voldemort with the second ingredient of
his regeneration potion at the end of
the day Pettigrew is just a follower and
he lacked the strength of character to
define or follow through with his own
core beliefs his allegiance was purely
where the power was and regardless of
whether that power
was driven by good or evil he has shown
us that he was willing to do whatever it
takes to support that source of power
Pettigrew is morally corrupt a symbol of
betrayal and a sniveling excuse for a
human being but at the end of the day he
did exhibit traits of both Gryffindor
and Slytherin and because of his desire
to be in Gryffindor at the time of his
sorting he was able to influence the
hats final decision ending up in
Gryffindor house and that's it for this
video what do you guys think why do you
think that Pettigrew ended up in
Gryffindor let me know down below if you
enjoy the content please remember to
Like and subscribe
until next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]
you